[Musik]
sankt moritz es winkt o'malley
mit dem hoteldirektor von patrick
bahners
sind konditorin flori stehen mit der
gourmetkoch fotografie ja
[Musik]
der beste partner und bergtour
als skilehrer für die ganze band die
kundschaft
[Musik]
es ist mitternacht und immobilien
gewährt sind hoch touren laufen
schnaitsee zwischen parat gemacht werden
für die wintersaison
schönebeck
hoffe sie sind wie sich die haie wärme
das ist zweite kapitel größere dok serie
und das frankreich wieder ganz gute
nachricht der hauptdarsteller von sankt
moritz und inter mailand ist inzwischen
betroffen es ist der schnee wird ohne
schnell aufgabe überhaupt nicht dass
schnee bedeutet zum beispiel für diesen
fahrer vom tisch die pole für den
berzdorfer vor jetzt jede nacht am
schaffen ist was heißt das für die
protagonisten das lag am rosa das eigene
kind gerade als erstes ist luxushotel
das ist der start für die saison
[Musik]
im luxushotel balazs löst wie sie
braucht freude
es ist höchste zeit so der hoteldirektor
hans wieder angst haben sie in die
saison der technik starten nämlich kurz
vor der tür
das neue kann man fast garantieren aber
dass wir jetzt saal bevor ich das land
ist es sensationell
trentini besser sie zwei tage rechnet
die ba
mit
dreckigen schuhe von pallas
mitarbeiterstand das lied nicht drin
hans wieder mal als in die mitarbeiter
für die neue saison
wir sind also bereit für die eröffnung
es geht letzte instruktionen vom
direktor der staat diese kerbe risch
einer von 550 gestellt wo während der
wintersaison balazs schaffen sie sind
also alleine
sie besticht abgeholt
große familie
eine musik die sie
[Musik]
noch nicht
[Applaus]
zum saisonauftakt gibt es erstens
obligate gruppe viertel
[Musik]
wenn's hotels sind dornröschenschlaf
erwachen denn günter krell noch
mithelfen werden auch sie zu
heinzelmännchen
[Musik]
und langsam verwandelt sich hotel ein
smiley schluss
nur noch 40 stunden bis die erste
staffel mit
[Musik]
wie der floristinnen monica beach in der
anti nicht hochbetrieb der große star
city gang an verzaubert ist
erst zwei halbwegs
es meistens so großes und wenn es
darüber in der halle statt
aber es ist alles recht großes
klettergerüst und
wenn man den abgang
die gäste reisen da ich eigentlich erst
ausgesehen wie es dort wirklich gewisser
wie vor der tür
am tag wurde eröffnet vorteile nur mit
dem stress im ganzen hotel
macht sich meistens eine stadt die ganz
große 70 zentimetern und lebe jetzt
eigentlich gerade ganz länge wenn auch
immer heller das leben so groß zu setzen
selbst was schlimm wenn du denkst du
noch ein vager oder den lift als ein
riesending und anstatt
wahrscheinlichkeit richtig so ich find's
ganz schön
aber überall in
gefahr
um so richtig jetzt
kostenlos über alle möbel verteilt
nun steht jetzt auch
[Musik]
alles wieder da wo es hingehört der
hoteldirektor wie dem euro ergibt sich
aber alles noch ganz genau dem
kritischen blick entgeht
es ist für die mailänder
denic und sabrina nußbaum ist es
skilehrer fahrer sind es sinn macht
fußball rat vor ihrem auftraggeber ein
richter buss italien er am bahnhof st
moritz karg und darum sind setzt am
terrasse ruhm
hayward 7 schön wie sah so
dass man in der schnee dann hört man
muss probieren das ziel gebohrt und ja
dass das jemand im verlauf meines falte
mir war das auch so ich nehme das nur er
ist so schön
unberührten schnee denn laut deutlich
mit im schnitt unterwegs oder arbeitet
er seit die man auch dass zu wenig geld
ständig
sieht die ruhigen als bitter für sie
aber für den notfall gibt zwar immer
noch schneekanonen und ihr werdet per
helikopter überall der theke was braucht
werden
josie ende oktober tritt regelmässig
künstlich beschneit
[Musik]
die villa am legendäre suvretta hang für
sankt moritz gehört dem chef des
nussbaums
direkt aus mailand reist der luca
bassani zusammen mit seiner tochter
weiteres bauteil sankt moritz blieben
sie mehr als 20 jahre schafft es
nußbaums sowie der achterbahn derzeit
sind soll bis wir freunde wurde
der italiener luca bassani hat sich
große vermögen mit dem bau vor
weihnachten gemacht aber die zweite
liegenschaft ist wintersport
es ist immer wie ein traum wenn man im
schnee kommt von den freunden erwartet
wird das haus schon geöffnet und geheizt
ist kurz einfach ein traum
pflicht des nussbaums könnt wie dieses
skifahrer mit dem chef fuß
[Applaus]
was sagen ja ich
großartig dass martina sie und dass die
vision für sie sind sehr willkommen
danke vielmals für dich gerade als
panorama
dieses panorama sagt moritz kenne den
blick auf den silber planer sehen und
den jump fehler sehen
wie sie sehen ist dieses haus modern und
traditionell zugleich
wenn wir das bei den ball mit rechnen
sind es 1200 meter
das ist kein problem
ich spreche nie über geld
ja ist besitzen um es wieder auszugeben
oder möchten sie vielleicht eines tages
die reichste person auf dem friedhof
sein das bringt sie nicht
während meiner haustüre chromes nußbaums
der hofplatz
und dieser präsentiert düste luca
bassani schon die nächste überraschung
das ist eine art james bond accessoires
die geschichte beim rock röhre
es ist ein große lift den sie mit dem
auto befahren können
während die lunte fahren können sie alle
boote bestaunen die meine firma
herstellt
und wie viel ein
ich habe bereits gesagt es ist nicht
eine frage des geldes sondern eine frage
der qualität
einheimische faust auf
nein es ist alles wichtige unternehmer
unser erster kunde war zb lindsay owen
jones der präsident von l'oréal oder
der sohn von herrn murdoch james murdoch
ich finde sie sollten sich auch eines
kaufen es würde ihr leben und ihre
freizeit bereichern
verholt ziemlich die zweite villa kam
luca bassani fertig gebaut wurde und
alltag sieht mit deutlicher mehrheit
nicht nur geld er hat auch stil im boot
oder dem hus bauer geschmack und design
bestimmt das leben und das worden ist
davos ist das vergesse ich
plane dieses haus langfristig zu
vermieten
nach fünf jahren würde ich jetzt meinen
kindern überlassen
das muss für signierte wie viel mist ich
also quasi unter freunden da wir freunde
sind kann ich ihnen einen rabatt
gewähren ich würde ihnen das haus für
anderthalb millionen im jahr überlassen
schweizer franken das ist günstig
er hat das ich will kein stück
ist einfach jemanden zu finden sie ein
haus sucht aber es ist schwierig leute
zu finden die so viel geld ausgeben
höhere über sankt moritz auf der
corviglia auf knapp 2400 meter sieht
marmit zwei restaurants vom reto mathis
er ist in schuss sei erwartet vita mit
das ist chinesisch gaben aareal bank
welt hängt eben shangri-la auf tobias
van riesen chinesische schenkel aber
kimi kinesio kaviar ich sagte ja wie
sehr geschickt hat das qualitäts
attribut der maschine sagt in dem zimmer
hat natürlich schon verstanden und zu
gast ist wirklich skeptisch
wie sie treffe ich ihn
sie ist neu im team ist voll am rotieren
baby ist sehr frühen nachmittag
bevor die party weiter
ein kochbuch
beschützt und wurden fragen
respektiv das produkt das ist keine wm
auch keine verbrennt und das nicht zu
wenig zu sagen was immer sie aber eine
richtige ich muss dafür gehen geld und
geschenke maschine flucht vor krieg
dollar wenn das gepäck
[Musik]
hobby gestartet oder ist da drüben keine
trüffel
[Musik]
sls ist ein spezieller tag it fand die
neue saison morgen
von balazs rotierende chef patissier
stefan gerber und system alles läuft
rund so war das passt von der größe her
dass sogar das bild gut
ich mir das noch einmal in
der woche vom luxushotel
giftnotruf das alles wird frisch gemacht
organisator karl otto kontrakte
was wir noch brauchen ist hochschule
müssen noch kochen für die anreise sechs
kilo himbeer ungarin dora macht ich
gerade da sich ihre erste saison im
luxushotel
mit oder unentschieden mit oder ohne
klumpen
ist okay
ist das gut so
ich glaube nicht jetzt müssen wir
einiges machen müssen wie du darfst das
nicht so machen wir mussten zuerst einen
teil vom vom büro erhitzen und wenn du
dich an tina erhitzt ist curry ist kalt
was passiert stellt ihn
genau wird sofort fest und du bist nicht
so schnell du kannst es nicht rund ums
haus zu treten drin du verstehst was ich
meine die fäden berg das darf nicht sein
so auf gehts schnell warm machen
und gas geben jetzt
flüssig ist
ok damit durch passieren
zweite mal kurz zwar besser aber der
cheftrainer der sache im honig
so in den trichter und abfüllen in die
portionen
dieser erließ im jahr gestellt ob sie in
kruse geschworen hat gottes willen
der ersten tage und wochen muss man die
leute natürlich führen das ist sicher in
der großen küche ist dass man ist
ruckzuck verloren hier
gerade in der palast küche mit
verschiedenen nationalitäten
je nachdem kommen immer auch die person
darauf an aber die ersten tage ist nicht
unbedingt die leichten aber so ist das
im leben
der neue wellness tempel von ballast im
direktor wieder mal sein ganzer stolz
endlich ist fertig doch
wer hätte das gedacht
dass jedem euro gefüllt
das passiert alles neu in der nächsten
stunde
hier war
unruhig
20 millionen franken hat umbau kostet
jetzt zeigt sich der wellnessbereich
schon fast in voller pracht
dass da viel zu haben
das sind künstler von hier oben
heute ist nach ansichten
[Musik]
neues paar hat frau vom direktor plant
und verwirklichen
hast du das team beisammen ja das habe
ich dann treffen wir uns oben bei der
rezeption
nur eine stunde bevor spa eröffnet wird
wieder direkt und mitarbeiter gesehen
wir möchten ihnen danken es in den
letzten tagen so flexibel waren
ich möchte mich im besonderen auch bei
meiner gattin bedanken für ihren einsatz
ich weiß sehr wohl wie oft sie tag und
nacht sieben tage in der woche während
der vergangenen drei jahre an diesem
projekt gearbeitet hat
ich wünsche euch eine gute wintersaison
[Applaus]
es ist wie eine geburt ganz wunderbar
auch wenn es sich nur um eine innovation
handelt es ist ein neuanfang
wir haben ein großartiges team das gut
funktioniert
ich freue mich dass es jetzt losgeht
[Musik]
wittenberg berlin art gott jetzt wie
roddick das gottheit zur ist untrennbar
die nach zwei stunden skigebiet
[Musik]
dobel im restaurant miethig main obwohl
in schuss
der calwer schon bei anderen fragen nach
vorbereitungen fürs bank rät sind die
letzte zug
darf stars gasquet fr party ein
immobilienhändler und
[Musik]
somit die
107 und regie
jede gastwirt persönlich begrüßt wurde
mal oder wasser
auch im stahlbau mlinar sportlich noch
nicht fähig aber er hat sie die helfer
sind und seine frau paket mit
[Musik]
dem
start sieht
wahrlich alle 15 sind und
man selber die auto stieg und
nach europa der
sprecher
[Musik]
spacex gut genug für die stiftung
und sogar suche personal mit grund so
freute posiert mit dem ganz prominente
gast
formel 1 pilot offenbar aber eher ein
bekannter von der immobilie dame
vorne im spies freut sich stifter
erstickt
für mich dass es gleich zu dem was so
panisch im winter über mit
wobei die hektik und stress sind auch
ich mal dahin geschäft von macau tower
moment so tröger moorweg mit der
auszeichnung
diskutiert ob sitzt mit weil am stiel
eine zahl will oder ob die es da viel
milch gibt oder weg 70 da haben wir das
diskutieren dass der spitzenausgleich
zum zum tagesspiegel wird
jetzt geht es aufwärts familie gut lief
ihr hobby
[Musik]
ok marco machen kann
und was sonst noch so los
[Musik]
denn bitte mit dem kopf zu kurz
während die nes gourmet menü auf den
tisch grund sind die pisten arbeiten am
krampf aufhört guest schließlich wenn es
direkt präparierte pisten wie der
general
das ist auch eigentlich ist in zwei
stücke gerissen
für die neue mannschaft der marmit ist
sehr still bankett und alles klappt
für port wintersaison ich bestanden
[Musik]
dadurch sorgt der schnee auf der straße
sitzt koch
hessischer weltcup in wahrheit zu sagen
[Musik]
am nächsten tag ist es ruhig um im
ristorante mit auf der corviglia
und automatisch die sehr genau wie beim
englischen semo vorgedacht geht es
einfach sie haben
das jetzt im moment überhaupt kein
material sich selber ist die ganze
hektik werden wir wunderschöne blaue
stunde
monster schönes glas als entschädigt für
vieles für die ganze stress und für die
ganze hektik und so weiter weg sagt
mein kind ist er
familie kunst kurz das ist ganz klar
also dass ist das ist ja sollte aber das
ist keine ausstellung hatten meist
vorher glaube ich weil das parlament dem
kinder sind heil hat meine frau ist
angeklagt das ist ihr heilig mit
kliniken verschult aber ich persönlich
muss ich sagen kann das ganze kiefer
nach
was ich mir das ganz schön wenn die
selbe raus typ sie passte da irgendwie
sehr gut so in die welt der schönen und
ich habe ihnen gesagt dass sie ihren job
das team macht es persönlich richtig
spaß
wenn sie den spaß machen sie sich auch
dass ich irgendwas kbc sowie heiße ich
ganz klar dass mein vater auch seit
bestehen für geister sieht fast aus wie
sie sagen schön oder prominente des
jahres guten recht aber das ist ein gast
dass ich das geschäft ist im grund nur
geschäftliche blick und wendig wie eine
möglichkeit jetzt gefasst ist wenig der
gastgeber hat sich berufe anders sieht
er vom tisch das muss man respektieren
hat sich schwer wieder ganz da wird ganz
entscheidend sein also moralische
bedenken wenn jetzt das noch als hülle
und wels mantel mit diamanten
müssen wieso
hier ist es ist ein traum für sag ich
lieber das nicht sagt zumindest der
ökologisch das sozial- oder wegen mehr
ruft leichter wenn das ist das sind im
frühjahr alten blöcke seid ihr denn die
gesellschaft und ich bin dabei von einer
karenzzeit ich bin ein teil von denen
ausschweifender während gleich wenn sie
möchten und ich mache das gerne ich
mache positiv die provokative soll auch
provozieren aber es ist nicht klar wo
man hier ganz europa tour das treffen
stand des vorjahres malouda und der
indizes das ist aus der verband
macht also muss ich auf kalk um
subventionen das wort also sich ganz
klar ich stehe für das wohn ich schäme
mich nicht für das überhaupt nicht ich
bin stolz dass ich da quasi mit dem knie
verzichten ihm als als bespiel
hergestellt werden weil ich liebe es
auch und ich glaube es konsequent und
ich bin überhaupt nicht das ist quatsch
sagt ist was man im rahmen vom vortag
geschmack die von respekt das sind da
wenn einer seite wenn es da ist damit
mit bahn oder mit gabriels machen nicht
klar aber ich muss es für das was ich
bekannt bin ich
hoffentlich
denic nußbaum chauffiert im privatauto
der luca bassani mit seiner entourage
zum wie händler
der empfang ist herzlich der
italienische unternehmer schließlich ein
guter und
[Musik]
der richtige start klammere der
unterlagen fleischer im wert von 100000
franken
es gibt keine die unglaublich teuer sind
[Musik]
der qualitätsunterschied zwischen sehr
teuren und günstigeren weinen ist jedoch
nicht mehr so groß
wie viel kostet der kostet 450 franken
können wir eine flasche degustieren
selbstverständlich wollen sie den 99
unter den 96er die 99er
die hatte ja
[Musik]
zitieren wie kenny großes problem für
mich und da ja ich dann eine qualität es
war sehr schwierig diesen baum zu finden
geben sie mir zwölf flaschen von dem her
[Musik]
der li na hat große worte die der
mittelstation markus of the heli gibt
muss er mit seinen kollegen labine
sprengen
zum gehen' sich usa künstlich linie
schneelawinen auslöse wird hochsaison
buchs nur zusätzliche piste
der lineare geschärft je fünf kilo
schwere sprengsatz und riss präzis ab
jedes jahr explodieren so allein st
moritz und umgebung zweieinhalb tonnen
sprengstoff für sicherheit von der
wintersportler
[Musik]
auf den tisch im
palast mit flori stehen mit ihren blumen
kunstwerk
das da ist die legendäre hans patrol
zweete sie drei der name von
gründervater vom hotel palazzo auf 280
quadratmeter könnte sich
als relativ ruhig noch also damit
gestern auf platz eins an einer stelle
und ohne spitz weniger heiß umlagert
wie die andere
war so luxuriös wie er muss die tasche
langen musik franken kostet 1 8 und mir
da haben wir das wieder nur für
mindestens zwölf nicht da war der nasa
sowie über 200 franken
jetzt muss ich das neue team vom chef
patissier das erste mal bewiesen die
private party in dallas - 300 sl
vorbereitet
ja da hat es noch da hat es noch
gereicht aber trotzdem nicht kommen wir
haben nicht mal die hälfte
das steht vom gelben trikot
ja ich war der erste nicht gemacht das
sind 9 drauf ja
wie viele orangenfilets machst du
[Musik]
hast du den ersten teller gesehen
ist ok hab zwei minuten aufgepasst
punkt comcom und da müssen wir uns auf
nummer einigen mama achten
ich habe mir vor entsprochen hat 2009
auf geht's mal acht meter soll ist auch
okay aber ich dachte
hier steht noch ein geld was hatten es
hier verloren
rosina wer hat s gehabt aber natürlich
fritsch
der skilehrer nick nußbaum 14 genug aber
sahen dies als erste mal auf ski
[Musik]
autonomes bestieg noch jungfräulich
unberührten pulverschnee
[Musik]
selbstverständlich voraus und skilehrer
nick kennt natürlich überall die beste
hängt
[Musik]
die ballers kiez hoch absurd
willkommen zu hause
der ehemalige chefs sie zum hotel und
der hans jörg butt mit seiner frau anni
co
es kam sie direktorium von noten
ballaststoff um die beiden begrüßen
dort lebt während der wintersaison
ständig im hotel
beim chef patissier gerber
chef in fünf minuten gehts los
panik steigt
ich weiß nicht was glück ist aber
aber wer macht gold machst du gold
was vergoldet das gold das gold 22 karat
oder 24 karat
schau dir das herz oben ist die spitze
vom herz und der turm oben und in das
herz
schau dir bitte die herzspitze unten das
so schwer
letzten 2
halo
schlafen
[Musik]
wenn dem riesigen christbaum warum
barroso teil zum ersten mal gezündet
werden deshalb sank zum rezept das hat
tradition da oben und antwortete kess
mischen sich unters volk
mit dabei sind natürlich alte hans-jörg
butt roten seine frau
also wird wintersaison feierlich
eröffnet wie es gehört vom hoteldirektor
bitte mal persönlich meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe kinder
wie jedes jahr herzlichen dank dass sie
so zahlreich erschienen sind mit uns
zusammen die lichte unseres
weihnachtsbaums anzuzünden
ok bitte helfen sie den zu zählen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
thun im dow sind und westen auf der
corviglia sind schon wieder geschafft
was hat sagte jens schön und die anderen
system grund streng es wirft
novembermorgen wird
sorgenfalten auf der stirn von
teamkollege
länger sehr tiefer werden er ist einfach
mitsingen kann zieht am strengen der
wiener linien und es wird richtig werner
zimmermann
im dritten kapitel vor sankt moritz als
weltweit da sind sie sicher wieder mit
wii oder
move sie unter schönen abendessen kochen
[Musik]